I hope this is working alright some of
my expert looks a little bit weird hey
open this end again why is this looking
strange anyway I hope that works out
fine I would welcome some feedback if
this dream is working fine um
I know after going live for an
unexpected time it takes a moment for
people to show up but what I want to do
is today tonight does involve the
viewers I want to play some games
against ya viewers of the stream so if
you are watching this and if you have
only chance you can challenge me so
let's just get this going put out some
challenges three minutes - five minutes
yeah maybe not bullets that's a I always
feel it's a little bit tricky if you
play if you mix some three minute 5
minute and bullets but three and five is
fine I also do of course increment 3 + 1
3 + 2 whatever you like so I'm happy to
take em to take challenges I have not
yet gotten one but it will just be a
matter of matter of minutes I hope until
I get some challenges of course I can
play a random game you know let's do
that I have never the person will
probably want to rematch so I'm just
waiting until I get a challenge I
haven't gotten one yet surprisingly
so I'll just wait for the challege to
pop up don't have one
anybody around that wants to challenge
me
huh okay yeah I don't want to wait much
longer so good you basically play one
and now I get a challenge exactly this
moment okay come on it's I think it's
okay if I have bought at this precise
moment like on the first on the first
term so me Luck's 96
let's let's get going here I've got five
minutes and I'm going to start with the
with the fake head oh you can almost
against anything you can play those four
moves just build a house as friends off
of me tend to say yeah counselor first
well this is actually five plus five
that's long yeah please everybody
challenge me I didn't see that it's a
bit long five plus five early that is
rapid not blitz right okay I'm going to
play quick
yeah I think I'm what I tend to do is to
not make it longer then like if you add
the two two figures 3 plus 2 5 plus 1 1
plus 2 it should be something where if
you add those two should be between 3 &
6 so your zero yeah five zero is okay
anything from two zero to five plus five
plus one I think it's okay
this is a tattoo long I didn't I didn't
see it beforehand they just said I feel
that people wait
now it's okay we thought it's okay I
mean I didn't tell you before so you see
the apologizing in the in the chat no no
need to it's just that for the future
challenges let's do let's do it a little
bit quicker I'm going if five the month
I always complicated completely on
position tab okay I'm going to take him
and do q1 support the center yeah black
it's not that in that bad shape or I can
take now on c5 right
that cannot be bad I guess
I guess no really good I almost has to
go back yeah now before yeah I guess why
not
yeah thanks for following me I need to
change that said that it's somehow
readable I don't know what I did there I
mean it looks strange must be possible
to simply get get the font smaller yeah
he trapped his own night bill I did it
has it whole square
yeah thanks for playing I have a couple
of more challenges is the drunken lawyer
cool off yeah let's let's go with ace
ace one eight eight six and let's see
maybe well I want to say let's go for
our King zinnia for a change but I get
the London system quite often I was
actually a good move after taking ninety
five is annoying
so let's go back to c7
yeah hello - Don X for me I got to hear
that you are back to playing chess my
goes back to D - hmm doesn't feel Magnus
is not on I just cheat so okay we have a
London system me I'm going to play the
double V Aikido against it's fairly
reliable setup that I've played a lot
White has to take care of the 97
threatening e5 now almost
[Music]
I'll take that yeah this has given up
the exchange but I don't really believe
it but it could get messy for sure I did
not I don't know what I Plays are
finished in the titled arena I am I had
to stop playing because my connection
was too bad so it was something and a
100 something I stopped after roughly 30
or 40 minutes it was an extremely strong
field oh yeah and then I did a cupid
thing on on Magnus's game so I know what
he did in the tournament it was pretty
awful and awful beating that the
opponents had to suffer so what to do
here and it's centralized yeah I'm an
exchange up and I don't know there's not
much compensation yeah sure I'm going to
make more chasuble repertoires I'm
currently working on a new for based
repertoire
and it is already fairly farm progressed
it did not it will not be long until it
is released I think we're talking
February problem there's still some
details Bishop to c4 it's looking on
Jeff's Everman okay I have to push the
this night away on h3 it really sucks
scream frozen hmm you should probably
refresh that this often helping okay so
how am I going to play here I think I
should put this in the corner maybe a
five yeah here I was thinking this is a
good movie threatening rook takes e4 and
threatening the bishop so I can take the
bishop and if he takes the knight I play
here and win the Queen yep
so thank you for playing ace the London
system so I'm going to start with the
other challengers let's aim drunk and
annoy a fairly underrated here on that
side here he's a good opponent
I've played him quite a bit on chess 24
so oh and he knows what I like and what
I don't like place my own repertoire
against me oh my goodness
we need only gas on niches so I know we
nobody needs him
okay if you would play a fine but I
don't care much yeah this is a good line
of course very solid line this is
actually part of my wide repertoire the
Scotch for Knights now White has some
one thing definitely in his favor and it
is the the structure in the pawn
structure that white has is extremely
sound black's pawn structure is slightly
weakened just a bit it's not much it's
basically the isolated a pawn and the
slightly weak DMC pawn him so it is not
like blankets of trouble but why does
playing let's say based on a very Sun
sorry very a sound strategic base
let's see yeah please
you can challenge me that is the point
I'm playing and playing people on here
in the chat please go ahead and
challenge okay I'm going to see five and
now okay this is a debatable decision
but it is interesting going to try to
play on the dark squares and basically
claimed that the white Bishop on f5 is
yeah it's kind of you know it's it's not
attacking anything it's basically placed
on squares where nothing happens yeah
you know you're not going to meet me on
h7 here so this bishop is not a very
useful piece on the other hand I may be
able to do stuff on the dark squares
this is the idea and he weakens the dark
squares a little bit more yeah it's so
difficult to do something Ruby 7 was to
make the knight removable yeah how to do
that how to play nanite 94 doesn't have
it doesn't do anything a Muslim Queen if
Queen f5 maybe I'm not sure about all
this
the absolute total thing with tournament
prices is them a good cheating detection
if you can guarantee that guarantee is
probably difficult but if you can
somehow be reasonably sure that nobody
cheats online then then online chess
tournaments will be extremely popular
and I mean of course there is always
incentive to play em over the board
chairs Wolfe Anderson's bulletproof
strategic report over there there's a
book like that that's fantastic really I
have to check that out I was thinking
about stuff like that basically writing
something like let myself yeah how to
draw with white or something like that
it's it's a little bit making funny a
little bit it's super solid repertoire
for white it's not not bad let's it's
somewhat true when a gas is playing many
openings that wolf under saunas champion
that's true
so here I'm basically improving my
pieces here in this game you see that
I'm on on dark squares mostly how do I
play him that move looks a little bit
wrong if you ask me but I wonder I can
actually check and then play 94 it took
me a moment to understand that oh thanks
for the donation um I have to say if I'm
not thinking if I don't think for the
nation it just me overlooking it yeah
it's
I still have to somehow get used to to
the whole twitch thing and it's
sometimes difficult for me to see all
the things happening at the same time
okay this is actually quite annoying
here I cannot take the porn as I wanted
rook takes this Bishop d3 as usual when
developer defended here by the drunken
lawyer
hmm I don't see anything great yeah
amazingly
yeah I'm not happy with this
not at all group shake see 592 Luke c3
when I was Bishop d3 and I didn't see
much happening yeah why dispatcher here
but maybe I'm okay maybe I'm okay
I don't know I can take he I can check
again young probably yeah huh
say anyway to play this for win I don't
think so
well played well played I think that was
okay I mean a fair results what I'm
trying to say okay
cool hope I'm going to go a form so we
have a dragon it's a sewing dragon going
to play with long castle tennis OPH okay
poopy eight looks feels a little bit
slow
five I can take take just six right oh
okay yeah there is a new cherry chef ski
book coming out yeah this is something
that I have to check yeah it's it's a
little bit strange that all of a sudden
there would be a new book by him I mean
he has written this classic endgame
strategy from 1980 something like that
it's a really old book but it's a modern
classic so it looks a bit if he there
the counter
can I do that let's do it like that it
doesn't look so strange I wonder I
wonder about this book oh I can take the
eight No
yeah it's true is he still alive that's
a really good question obviously he is
yeah I wasn't aware yeah but it seems he
is still alive and he is obviously a
book to be released very soon and yeah I
don't know I mean we have to check it's
probably I think it's from new and
shares and sometimes new and chess they
simply take some old book and put some
some learn new things in there and then
sell it as a new one they did that
before g6 by Peru
[Music]
huh maybe maybe this makes sense now
with g6 to play in this in this way okay
it was developing she cannot be bad and
now if you very tempted to play h4 hmm
yeah I don't know if it is good okay
let's just cancel I'm I'm really I'm
really always I was always favoring like
healthy rules develop on centralize it's
always but then what I tend to do at the
end instead of something crazy so a good
plan is Bishop f4 Queen d2 Bishop h6 and
try to trade this and go for an attack
and the interesting point
do I take or not I think I'm taking
because I have this this good tempo and
whatever he does moving the Queen looks
ugly that specially seven rupees seven
stuff f6 is not playable Bishop f6 Queen
d2 also looks good man Bishop is
stronger here with the pond traded I'm
trying for Oh interesting
that looks helpful Quinton taking
already know but Queen f4 is a good move
[Music]
yeah sure Shakya seems to differ Gary oh
I heard that when I learned that this is
scheduled to be released soon ish and my
I have a friend of mine has a mail-order
chess chess books chess equipment
mail-order business and I order order
all the books there and he told me you
know there's a new sheriff ski book
coming out and like one really no it
wasn't it is it's not snowing at all
absolutely not
if anybody around with some knowledge
I'm sorry with some knowledge of Queen
g4 he wants to play let's do this first
off of expert I would really like to
those those messages like followers and
so on then that this is just smaller
like the font I couldn't get that
working it's a plugin from Stream labs I
don't know maybe maybe somebody is
around who's knowledgeable yeah he I
tried to checkmate on age seven my usual
simple self and after f6 husband taken I
don't see how he covers said I don't
think he can
okay and made next um that just said I I
don't know
isn't that a normal isn't it a normal
chess set
I mean somebody sent me stuff once but
I'm not really sure if I'm using one of
those or something standard I don't know
not a tech person I don't know if xsplit
is better than OBS or anything I don't
know I don't I don't have any knowledge
there when I started out some time ago I
was pointed to xsplit and I'm quite okay
with with it
Joseph Joseph is figuring out what to do
against the chick I think I used Eilish
I definitely have stylish in place
yeah here so this is a very closed
position very closed okay let me sorry
what that someone set me sent me a link
there okay now here I'm going to play in
a very simple fashion I'm just going to
take and now bring that Knight to d5
I know it's low but no Bishop h6 is not
a big deal he can castle earlier like
here like here it's an interesting
question
nykeya Bishop h6 you can just cancel
okay so Knight to d5 the material just
if Korea to display it I don't know
oops Oh Minj was a machine human sorry
sorry about the German I was to come to
our store next year yeah I cannot go g3
and h3 is also sick and now I don't want
to take I have to take now that's sad I
needed one more prophylactic move that I
would be would have been in really good
shape
yeah III what Bishop takes g3 and that
was a draw not nice yeah I mean I'm
still quite okay here not worse but it's
not really what I wanted to have and no
no bullet please at the moment i'm i'm
doing i'm playing the guys in the twitch
chat and I need some somewhat somewhat
similar time controls if it is too mixed
this able links and [ __ ] it's not a bad
idea actually how can I do that how do I
do that huh I don't know sorry guys I
don't know how to how to how to change
that
yeah I'm okay I'm okay yeah no worries
yeah okay
how can I make people mod hi I'm not
sure here
how can I make people mod I don't I
didn't find that no subscriptions are
not yet possible I need to get get the
affiliates tape first working on that
like this
so c5 he cannot take yeah I'm not sure I
think it's this must be a win should be
a win for a five-minute is okay of
course so let's get chick mate with the
Queen on the road okay yeah thanks for
helping with with moderation so let's
see why was a huge list here I'm going
to start on top and let's see Paul
morphine
so somewhat older challenge I guess
right yes sure
okay so let's grab on deform
see what happens okay oops what the heck
I'll take that okay yeah if you hit the
wall in terms of improvement it's it's
it's tough to say everybody is different
of course but it's it makes sense if you
feel like you actually I mean if you
actually work on chess and do stuff
learn practice things like that and you
still don't improve you should maybe
question if you really do the right
things if you don't do anything okay
there's no need really to complain but
if you actually invest time and nothing
happens it makes sense to maybe question
yourself a little bit about what you
what you practice if you practice the
right things oftentimes people who
invest time they don't invest the time
in a very wise way this is something
that is very individual of course so I
have to think for a moment I think I
actually have to take now it makes sense
maybe to analyze why you actually lose
games this is I know it sounds very
basic but
it is it is advisable simply to look at
your games and try to find out why you
actually lose games there can be all
kinds of things it can be also things
that are not directly related to due to
chess yeah maybe you don't have yeah I
don't have the stamina or you lack a
certain a certain experience with
stronger players it can be really there
can be so many things that it's
difficult to say but a good analysis
there of what you actually good at and
what you're not good at can can help
tremendously what did I do he went in
there placed five there was I was just
like delivering the speech
yeah it still should work but still kind
of weird what I did here
okay thanks for the game Paul morphine
that was really quickly played dear
santa-claus
it's got a really high rating close to
my rating okay so what is Center doing
okay yeah I have a hard time to follow
the whole chat if I'm playing I don't
know I think actually I have to I have
to somehow increase the front side of
that Chet it's so smallish I have a hard
time to actually read what you're
writing
I will check a minute there's a bit of a
bit of a boring line but it's not a bad
line
okay so it's not going to I was
expecting like to check on c3 but didn't
do that it surprisingly if I ran out of
tea my stream has to has to be finished
I definitely need some tea to get me
going the night xt5 was mostly trading
he had before coverage and I want to
keep the two isolated pawns there to
play against them oh that's an
interesting move
huh g2 is hanging
interesting
okay let's force him here this is this
is Roy Bush I don't know I don't know
what it is in English yeah it's red red
bush yeah in in in South Africa it's a
more of a herbal tea so it's it's no
problem to drink later in the day why
not be sure III I don't think it was
ever eagle to be honest was it legal
yeah so black has played this well
and our systems are often drank
non-alcoholic beer Anjali
wheat beer fights in beer which is
really fairly okay
for forum non alcoholic beer I can't try
to trace him let's see him yeah this
actually is a really good question that
was a question where why there are
different terms like a Germany yeah we
have gamma onion yeah but it's still
Deutschland it's it's a bit weird I have
no clue actually and I'm reasonable I'm
quite I'm quite I quite I'm quite
interested in history and and things so
I could really I could you that because
uh and there were some things there but
this is this I don't know
look on the open file looks very
reasonable okay um how to do something
here maybe it is just nothing going on
here it's possible I take this I can
actually go here use the king yeah he's
tied tied to c7 somewhat and I think he
actually has to keep the book on see ed
for the moment takes takes c6 this King
Disick's that looks annoying okay so in
vs. but now I'm ki can invade yeah let's
in wait yeah I know with subscriptions
you can do many interesting things you
can customize things nicely for the
channel that and something to check when
I'm when I'm there Bishop d7 maybe or
this one I think it's kind of okay I
have this and then Knight to c6 that's
the first point
okay so I have night before
so what to do here we can I can go all
the way to a seven hey sound and then
like group here and take on c7 so let's
be pawn is quick so Center get the beep
on promote it yeah thanks for the game
center very slowly played wow that's
that's a long list yeah very long list
and I want you actually I'm sorry guys
the ones I've played already I'm going
to decline so everybody just one game
that same um
so on that's cool let's go I don't know
I don't I will not be able to play all
the challenges I guess I was a donation
thank you what's Siri I cannot really
tell what what the donation was she
donated 1 million dollars to me thank
you very very much
yeah I don't know what happened what it
was I have to really adjust this how
does the player learn how to grind to
not have the same
yeah I want to you you know you're right
with the view account the thing is I
have the view account in the industry
because I want to see it myself I see it
now because I have to preview off the
twitch stream but I don't see the stream
itself it doesn't I wouldn't see it in
the actual preview window so this way I
know how many viewers I have yeah thanks
for the donation okay I'm going to take
that and now the Stokes it's a good
otter Swiss cheese formation yeah okay
just castle first
who
they are made in 47 things a lot for the
donations you donated more than once was
very happy to see that thanks a lot
Bullock ants book on the Kings Indian
yeah it it's it's good but I have one
issue that war Gong wrote this book
while ago and white whatever what am I
doing here I'm not doing this correctly
shouldn't have taken down it wasn't a
good idea I took him to the bone
formation is funny
so yeah the book is is ok yeah the
bargain book but he wrote this book some
they they are both good yet the rule
book and E 5 book him the ball guns
below guns what is that called actually
I forgot that like weapons but the skins
in the book he wrote this for some other
he wrote one like some years ago and
then they release Bordeaux Gans Kings in
here which is basically the same book it
is just like it has some edit on lines
but it's really not it's like you know
80% the same book and I really feel I
don't know you shouldn't make a new book
there if you just have a couple of if
you just have a couple of new things
yeah paunescu playing well here he P
defended this very well yeah now are the
age farm there are some
threats some pretty nasty threats
yes stylee thanks a lot for helping with
the moderation
let me check here I don't know am i
threatening okay
it's got chick here and I have to take
anyway so no need to think about this a
lot I still think I'm quite okay but my
idea now is be form so that the bishop
is distracted and then I can actually
take on d5 that's what this my DM one
good thing is then I'm ahead by more
than a minute am paunescu I have to move
once in a while I'm very happy by the
way about the connection my connection
does not seem to be a problem everything
so sex the Rope take take Queen takes
Queen g3 should stop things and now I'm
playing against this poor information
now now the C pawn has to do stuff yeah
and I'll take d5 then either taking or
playing c5 okay this one is actually a
good move so I'm winning the exchange
can check on b2 what I can just go to h3
doesn't feel like a problem and a
meeting okay thanks for playing am bound
SQ good job the real Donald Trump okay
yeah come on make the scotch game great
agree again or something
yeah what so here I'm going for long
castles okay so let's see what Donald is
up to I know what I do
yeah that's true well maybe there's the
real Donald Trump 18 19 20 more than 20
seems really like ads it's a lot so
yeah I'll make him pay for the night on
the 8th I can tell you okay so yeah I
can actually take on c5u greed is good I
know that it's going get a little bit
still I'll take the pawn it's not Donald
Trump so I just put this onto f5
yeah get the Queen somewhat closer
somewhat closer to to checkmate entire
trip yeah hmm yeah I don't want yeah I
don't know how to do that this is
actually not bad let's go here you can
check on see to what that is just like
one check that is tea I'm not drinking
whiskey on stream also probably wouldn't
drink whiskey anyway it's okay but I
know it looks a little bit like yeah
it has a really nice color to it really
is nice I really rarely drink alcohol I
do I like some beers I like some what
gas actually and when I was in Poland
that was really nice stuff what they
have okay so um what you do here cannot
take on h7 unfortunately I mean okay
this I saw that this wins but I was
thinking now something like what can
lemon vodka vodka orange this is good
stuff but really I could rarely it's
oscillations is the next one yeah I mean
I really think that should be should
keep it reasonable with the with the
alcohol I also like him I also like I'm
not sure about the English terms this is
this is Greek I'm stuffy who's o in
Germany I really like that
so we have a Maroc C mind
keep it cents or whatever well it's also
who's on English okay and learn
something
okay so what's this B tanks a six can
take on c6 I don't know a six talks a
bit weird it seems very backward or
black is doing here maybe you can still
play it like d6 but
okay oscillations he has to get
developed ignite age 65 maybe so yeah
the black is okay yeah probably taking
on c6 was not that great to be honest 97
is got f5 yeah no I understand what
yummy I could sing him with in the
maracas C&S sometimes the issue you
don't know to time the extension or that
well expansion is the right word
that's easy route p8 is a good move that
was I really played that badly and in my
favorite opening of all things am I
going to stream again tomorrow I'm not
sure maybe for a short while it's not
not not sure I have to work something on
my efore repertoire I want to get that
finished sooner and maybe a short stream
in the morning I'm not sure I decide on
those things spontaneously I am I
actually wanted to go to bed but then I
felt okay might as well play some play
some games and then I decided to make
that you know this enormous
this enormous tea
I felt okay I might as well yeah that
was the final final drops of the team so
when I'm when I get the tee tee finished
I'm probably stopping this yeah
oscillations heather has an okay
position but takes a really long time to
play no not bad not bad this is the
problem I have I don't really have good
squares I have to go here in order to
not repeat no I haven't been working
today I've been playing I had a play
that lets tournament actually today we
had our regional team blitz
Championships team teams of four yeah
the alert wouldn't know the window is
actually not the issue I mean okay this
is too big I know but the I couldn't
resize the fonts after get the fonts
like smaller
I don't want those big fonts but I
couldn't couldn't get them smaller yeah
what I try is I just try to regroup this
here trade trade the night would be
would be good
I'm very happy with with the result what
what we did in that in that team event
because we had a reasonably strong team
but it wasn't the best possible team
that we could have now I'm using
expletive stream we didn't have the best
possible team but we still managed
fourth place and we managed to qualify
for the next stage and that was fine
fourth place was a good result
Bishop c6 yeah yeah the thing is I know
how to resize the window this is
actually not a big issue but if I resize
the window you know I can resize the
window that's not an issue
let me I can I can make the window
smaller but the font is still enormously
big yeah I don't know
oscillation there seems to have some
some issues with with the connection he
loses lots of time very good I got 260
viewers that's nice
somebody hosted this year maybe I am I
really am very new to all this I only
recently learned that there is this
hosting I could also host others it
seems but I'm not entirely sure how that
you know the font is still big you know
I made this window smaller but I don't
know how to to shrink the font it looks
like his mate coming up
you know and like resigned yeah that was
actually well played I had some some
issues there and okay
dingdong 250 and it's that's fantastic I
don't know how many of us the show the
shows for me is he had I never checked
that was on YouTube it's a different
platform as well so dang dong playing
this
we are playing the maracas see point
this is good I like this
hey eve online i think this is probably
very popular right streams for eve
online that's a very popular game I
think okay I'm pushing this night back
and yeah is he doesn't really have that
that many squares after cream of their
screen to e4 check challenger one of the
chess brass to my job was well I'm happy
to play play those matches if I can get
it into my schedule yeah the black queen
now is in trouble can almost pre move
knight c6 you know this is how it looks
if you make it really really large funny
right I need to adjust that I mean a
small font would be completely okay
okay so that's that's cute right it is
cute
I had 94 but you know the solution
wasn't bad either yeah thanks for the
game ding-dong
Akane The Little Mermaid let's play The
Little Mermaid oh I'm on Hambleton did
commentary on the bathroom you death
trend death match I didn't watch that
actually was what it was that wasn't
interesting okay so
the ship chief alright
should be for us right I didn't watch
that match I mean I didn't watch that
match to be honest I was thinking that
John is a heavy favorite then I think he
won that quite convincingly that match
I mean I have ever played against long
strand air to have to save it
I have played against John and he's a
really good player I think so I felt it
was the favorite but I don't know it's
it's not a very scientific opinion just
whatever I failed
and is really good at volatile so yeah
the Little Mermaid is playing this quite
well I think
I think he's probably taking no it's
he's no what am I doing here
the Little Mermaid said she want it
interesting grammar question
yeah it's the moment is she on it they
okay
yeah made as a meat isn't a mate
definition or whatever yeah let's not go
there
okay so huh interesting
okay I grew up okay I think I can take
it
I'm sorry for that but I was a deist
able to stop the microphone ah never
have a slight cold it's not super
terrible but it bad but a bit yeah it
looks like I'm going to win it on time
against the mermaid
now it's not a big deal like that cold
wow I cannot do that this keeps
everything did Huy Fong blunder in the
end game again today I don't know I
didn't I didn't see the games I only saw
the results I am very interested in how
Cromley beat Ireland with black I saw
that it was it was an Italian game uh
you know you know I briefly saw the game
yeah
Magnus was better for sure for most of
that most of the game yeah I made the
window smaller now I don't even see if
it is a donation or the follow hey a
joined stream with Oprah Winfrey it
sounds funny yeah why not okay so I won
this game against a Little Mermaid so
yeah let's go Knicks game
yeah I wait a moment but it doesn't seem
to be on anymore okay
what's theory okay let's play what serum
I'm just going from top to bottom um
come on the pink oh okay f3 that's it's
a rare line but it's actually not that
terrible still quite a healthy
development ed white hassium
my looks that looks nice on that bishop
now is unprotected but can easily be ab
initio threatening c4 now actually I
already had gives me the pawn here on b5
yes but I have C for others to see fine
with that horn won't be too
he might get my c4 point somehow I don't
see how actually now that such as fun I
mean I have 93 that's a it's an
excellent square for the knight
year 93 of POVs active that sir always
good stuff in blitz queen with queen
okay so the only really annoying pieces
that rook I played this in order to play
queen bee aid now Queen b6 is actually
possible okay now he's got Knight f5
okay that is annoying queen bee eight
maybe I'm not sure about this
let's do it maybe knight c6 actually
okay is the temple that I just just
going just going to take not think about
this it that much I'm taking in the rook
here no it doesn't react to it
I'm cave I move the night as knight c6 I
mean that's not terawatt slightly
slightly annoying
that is a really bit of a pestis piece I
try to undermine it I take here I have
to do this first and then take it that's
better so that the Queen cannot capture
now I can just take the bishop
yeah thanks a lot for playing what's
theory doc 3ds yeah we going to this is
going this list is going to is getting
getting getting shortened there was a
question by the drunken no idea what
music I'm listening to I'm actually
listening to some music at the moment
may not like right now but I am I
offered do while working on on on chess
content like books or a chest of a
repertoire so it's it's a bit tricky I
cannot listen to all types of music when
I'm working some things were some things
okay sometimes listen to two classical
music actually if I'm working for from
doing like chess record for us books or
whatever because it is um it is not it
is without any lyrics yeah and this this
is actually helping me when I'm writing
because if I if I listen to lyrics that
sometimes rotates me crenate form isn't
that winning us tuning a bishop right
and another type of music that I
currently enjoy listening to it I'm not
really am I'm still in the process of of
kind of going through bands and and
details is some is what is sometimes
called Americana yeah this is like folk
country style but yeah sometimes a
little bit darker not this typical
country stuff that you that you maybe
maybe think of letter that I enjoy quite
a bit what I recently like a lot I mean
it's a band that does not exist anymore
they split up I think two years ago or
three years ago the civil wars it's a
great stuff yeah yeah I'm just a piece
upright I'm a bishop up
I did another piece up yeah I think I
will get I will get a pretty strong
attack as well yeah thanks for the game
duck 3ds Jankowski it sounds funny a
country music I kick my dog and the
truck towards that yeah yeah I know what
you're talking about some of this stuff
I think it's quite quite funny but I
like the like the I like the general
style of music even though some of the
things are probably a bit weird so let's
let's develop here I need to cancel my
hand but once this is completed my
position is pretty strong
yeah that's a pretty awful pin oh yeah I
know first aid kit um
you're completely right my pawns the
people I think I think I am I think I I
heard
listen to one of their songs on on that
on the radio and it's going to be tricky
to meet now I'm not drinking Coca Cola's
st and it's almost finished
yae-chan Gorski has a huge problem here
I mean this is almost not possible to
prevent I don't see how
you can concentrate well when you listen
to metal hmm I cannot do that
I really cannot focus I mean at least I
cannot I cannot do something really we
really need to think deeply yeah I
cannot do that I mean I could listen to
metal while playing some often blitz
games I could do that but I couldn't
really do something where I need to
focus okay so let's do the skin but the
genious gambit we need to yeah I know
this stuff this is actually how you play
it how is that how was the theory there
Bishop d6 I think it's been ages since I
check this yeah yeah he knows all the
stuff
okay I'm quite happy that I'm still
alive not that I mean oh it's tough yeah
yeah like he's got a new business a
community fresh account you know which
is not doesn't mean that it's fishy or
something but you simply don't know how
good to supply a place you know it could
be really strong
how to how do I get this developed this
disposition it's not so easy I cannot
move this bishop that easily
there's very slowish he played this
quite well yeah I was thinking my
development now is at least accelerating
which yeah I think you can hide the
pawns reading the Zen mode I think but I
never used that
no what is your students got to 1,500
that's good yeah
for eleven-year-old I mean okay that's
not Magnus version - but it's it's good
yeah okay so maybe I can win the h5 pawn
take this
go back here a 96 no not an issue now
I'm quite okay here you know it's
nothing great my white is actually
better him after Luke shakes Bishop my
bishop doesn't have good square that is
called Ruby 7 which I did not really
that didn't really register yeah here
just play it's not playing bad at all
95
I thought 95 but this is maybe better
even my bishop has very very very
limited scope
we've got dings good night f8
[Music]
I'm still hanging on for dear life
95 is the CA ever
miss his plane he's doing this okay my
my bishop has no squares is the problem
I mean at least I know hey I have an
idea how to how to find 95 a tree takes
just just about works
it's still still somewhat dangerous I
think
do this chick g3
[Music]
now well that's a tough game I'm going
to promote now P maybe I should have
played King f3 actually because this is
so not so easy
Quincy one made
III
Queen reformate is the idea
Quinn before text ex-king b5 King be
three kings c5 he has three take b-36
b27 no doesn't do work
Queen a1 made this idea
yeah it was really tough really tough
game we know I'm not taking any measures
sorry there's so many challenges still
on the list
naina yes let's go with the Umbreon so
now I think this is going to be the
final game and it's it's nearing 1 a.m.
here I need some I need some sleep
I think we before wasn't winning I
thought I looked at this I think he
draws with the pawn but came
yeah I'm playing this into somewhat slow
way I have to have to admit him but I
played this a bit quickly at the very
beginning and I somehow drifted into a
line that I have I don't really know
well this should be three is not what I
usually do but okay it should be should
be reasonable disposition
yeah no bringer is now taking a huge
timeout figuring out what you do know
I'm yeah with the e4 and play more
reform from a couple of reasons
actually the main reasons is that I have
a vast variety of students and I want to
I don't want to change let's say my
students repertoire if they are in four
players and do that well there's no need
to change to change that so I try to
learn a little bit more of money for
myself so that I can help my students
better that's one thing and in some
cases I want to test out this repertoire
that I'm developing for one you form it
sometimes it's tricky because I don't
have a huge experience with with with
Ronnie fine
I sometimes stumble into stuff okay that
I've just don't know like here that
looks like black is in good shape yeah
how do I actually cover
if ifs made on g2 not good
yes there's no subscription possible yet
to my channel because the YouTube has
just started the the twitch just started
basically I had this account for a long
time but I didn't stream in recent years
at all
and once I get to affiliate I think it
is called I could I can install such a
subscribe button yeah this is buti'm
really not yeah we both have strong
diagonals him
oopy 3G 3 something like that
Jim yeah blackest black is better here
but he's some taking a long time
just clean g6s a good wolf I mean yeah
and here he went for it it's a problem
hmm
I don't want to trade Queens but it's
tough to do tough to avoid so like it's
definitely better good stuff here by non
bring up
he takes a very long time there I played
very quickly at least oh this is five
plus three oh my god ah okay that's
actually longer than I wanted to play
okay so let's play this okay
g5 I tried to open this diagonal and
okay so maybe I can try to double on the
edge file let's try that I mean you can
take sit - what this is not an important
one yeah I can double against hmm and it
cannot cover that I don't know if I
would have played f5 that's lucky
because as long as the phone was I have
six if h7 was always covered and now
that's not possible
okay so we will go look at yourself okay
threatening now to take on g6 doesn't
win but it's not bad
take book h88 nope no one tried to
recruit me for the approach asleep and
would have been nice yeah I don't know
what you have to have some sort of local
affiliation and I don't know I don't
think there's German team and I didn't I
didn't check to be honest
try to yeah takes us mate look h8 mate
so we've got to go King f8 it's a bit
strange that he spends time here
idea now as we should be 5 and then g6
what just take take just take h7s
actually good oh that's surprising I'm
winning all kinds of stuff ok so I
turned this around or he turned it
around it's a bit of both king is 7 that
was stupid actually I was a bit stupid
ok that would have made things a bit
more difficult now I win that that rook
as well and the deep one I stop quite
easily ok
numbering I resigned to played very well
at at the beginning and then somehow
lost the thread a little bit ok I have
to go
guys it's 1 a.m. here and I need a bit
of sleep I hope you enjoyed the show
many viewers tonight that was very
enjoyable to do thanks about for
watching I will be on um definitely at
roughly the same time actually on Monday
Monday at 11:00 Central European Time
and evening I'm going to stream for
roughly 2 hours a little bit like that
like on Monday yeah maybe something
tomorrow I don't know yet yeah the
Sunday's my is its day off I will work a
little bit though and maybe start a
stream I don't know thanks a lot guys
till then bye bye